They made cutting class an art form
and gave an entire teen generation
a new perspective on life, love, and
proper car care. So what's the cast
of "Ferris Bueller's Day Off" doing now?
The question is, What aren’t they doing?
Though "Ferris Bueller's Day Off"
remains the defining film of his career,
Matthew Broderick's breakout role
actually arrived three years earlier,
when he played computer hacker David in
the cyber-drama "WarGames." A part in
"Ladyhawke" soon followed, and he then
became everyone's favorite enterprising
teen when John Hughes cast him in the title
role of 1986’s "Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
"Life moves pretty fast. If you don't stop and
look around once in a while, you could miss it."
After "Ferris" was a hit, Broderick kept
working steadily in film and television.
The decade following that film brought leading
roles in "Glory," "The Freshman," and "The Cable
Guy," not to mention the voice of the adult
Simba in the iconic Disney classic "The Lion
King." Other memorable movies for Broderick
include 1998's "Godzilla," "Election," and
Disney's "Inspector Gadget." But Broderick
was also an accomplished stage actor and
used that experience when he nabbed
the starring role in the 2001 stage
adaptation of Mel Brooks' "The Producers"
and then its 2005 film. Twenty years later,
he still divides his work between stage and
screen, and in 2023 he had a supporting role in
the adult comedy "No Hard Feelings" as well as a
lead role in the Netflix miniseries "Painkiller."
Like his co-star, Alan Ruck's career also started
to take off in the early 1980s. After early roles
in films like "Class" and "Bad Boys," he landed
the part of Ferris' best friend Cameron Frye
in "Ferris Bueller's Day Off." Ruck had the task
of playing everything Broderick's Ferris is not,
and he did it so well that he steals just about
every scene in the movie with his anxious comedy.
"Cameron what's gonna happen
to it, it's in a garage!"
"It could get wrecked, stolen,
scratched - breathed on wrong!"
Ruck continued to act regularly
through the rest of the 1980s,
but the 1990s was where he really got prolific
with his work on the big and small screens. If
you only know him as Cameron, you might
be surprised to realize that he was also
gunslinger Hendry French in "Young Guns II,"
and played Captain Harriman in "Star Trek:
Generations." He landed on
television not long after,
starring alongside Michael J. Fox in the network
hit "Spin City" as Chief of Staff Stuart Bondeck.
More than a decade later, he joined
the main cast of the short-lived TV
remake of "The Exorcist" as Henry Rance, and
beginning in 2018 was part of the ensemble of
HBO's award-winning drama "Succession."
He's never left the movies, though,
appearing in "War Machine" in 2017, 2023's
"The Burial," and the sequel to "Wind River."
Aside from "Ferris Bueller's Day Off," Mia Sara
is also remembered for her standout performance
as Princess Lili in the Ridley Scott-directed
fantasy epic "Legend" opposite Tom Cruise. She
followed that up the very next year when
she took on the part of Ferris' aloof but
charming girlfriend Sloane Peterson. As
Sloane, Sara added a level of cool to
the often goofy antics of her co-stars while
still being in on the joke the entire time.
Of course, Hollywood took notice of this opening
one-two punch, and Sara spent the next two decades
working regularly in film and television.
Unfortunately, she struggled to find the same
level of success as she did in the mid-'80s.
While she did appear in some popular films,
including "Timecop" as the wife of Jean-Claude
Van Damme's character, her later career never
matched her mid-'80s hits. That said, she
is notable for being the first actor to play
Harley Quinn in live-action, nabbing the role in
the short-lived "Birds of Prey" series in 2002.
Sara stepped away from acting in the early
2010s, and one of her final roles was as
Princess Langwidere in the film "Dorothy and
the Witches of Oz" and its miniseries. After
leaving Hollywood, Sara embarked on a career
as a poet and devoted time to her family.
Though Jennifer Grey only performed in fewer
than a dozen roles over the course of the '80s,
several of them proved to be classics. In 1984
she co-starred in "Red Dawn" with Patrick Swayze
and had a small role in "The Cotton Club"
from director Francis Ford Coppola. Then
she played Jeanie, the smarmy, vindictive
sister of Matthew Broderick's Ferris in
"Ferris Bueller's Day Off." While that
part garnered some attention for her,
it was her role as Baby in 1987's
"Dirty Dancing" that made her a star.
Off-screen, however, Grey was quietly dating her
"Bueller" co-star and on-screen brother Broderick,
and the pair were involved in a devastating
head-on car collision just before the release of
"Dirty Dancing." A woman and her adult daughter
were both killed as a result of the crash,
and the tragedy haunted Broderick and Grey
for many years, physically and emotionally.
Over the next decade, Grey continued to work but
failed to regain her star status, appearing in
lesser-known films like "Wind" and "Red Meat."
She took a break from acting after the birth
of her daughter in the early 2000s and appeared
mostly on TV after her return, which also included
a memorable appearance on Season 11 of
"Dancing with the Stars." More recently,
Grey showed up in recurring roles on "Grey's
Anatomy" and the "Roseanne" reboot "The Conners."
Lyman Ward's screen acting career stretches
all the way back to the 1970s, when he began
appearing in guest roles on TV show classics
like "Bonanza," "Battlestar Galactica," "One
Day at a Time," and the very first episode
of "Laverne & Shirley." He continued to work
regularly throughout that decade, and by the
1980s he was appearing in films like "Protocol,"
"Moscow on the Hudson," and "A Nightmare on
Elm Street 2: Freddy's Revenge." As Ferris
Bueller's father in "Day Off," he brings a
sense of likable cluelessness to the comedy
After "Ferris Bueller," Ward stayed working, with
credits including "Murder, She Wrote," "Family
Ties," "JAG," "Monk," and many more. In the 2010s
his acting work began to slow down, though he had
a major role in an episode of "Transparent"
in 2015. Hollywood wasn't his only career,
though. Turning to writing in the 2010s, Ward
published his first novel, "Fortune's Tide."
Cindy Pickett's breakthrough as a screen
actor came in 1977 when she was cast on
the long-running soap opera "Guiding Light,"
where she appeared in 22 episodes. By the 1980s,
more TV and film roles were flowing in, including
appearances on some major hits like "Magnum, P.I."
She secured the role of
Ferris Bueller's mother Katie,
who plays opposite star Matthew Broderick in
some of the film's funniest early moments as
the teen uses her to convince the
world that he's sick. Oddly enough,
her on-screen husband Lyman Ward later became her
real-life husband, though they divorced in 1992.
After "Bueller," Pickett showed up
in the 1987 TV miniseries "Amerika"
and the "Abyss" knock-off "DeepStar Six."
In the 2000s, she was as active as ever,
making single-episode stints in shows like
"Burn Notice," "Saving Grace," "The Client
List," and "The Mentalist." Outside of "Ferris
Bueller's Day Off," of course, Pickett is best
known for her role as Dr. Carol Novino in the
award-winning medical drama "St. Elsewhere."
Edie McClurg became beloved to audiences of
the '80s thanks in no small part to her role
as Principal Rooney's eccentric secretary,
Grace, in "Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
"He jeopardizes my ability to
effectively govern this student body."
"Well, makes you look like
an ass is what he does, Ed."
She was no newcomer to Hollywood, though, and
in the mid-1970s she had been a regular on
"The Richard Pryor Show" and "Tony Orlando
and Dawn" and had a brief role in the film
"Carrie" before she hit her stride the following
decade on "Harper Valley PTA" and "The Dukes."
At the movies, outside of her role as Grace in
"Bueller," McClurg was a recurring presence in
Cheech & Chong projects like "Cheech & Chong's
Next Movie" and "The Corsican Brothers." She
also had cameos in "Mr. Mom" and "Planes, Trains
& Automobiles" before her appearance as Chastity
Pariah in "Elvira: Mistress of the Dark." The
'90s saw her in a number of fan-favorite films
like "Flubber" and "Natural Born Killers,"
as well as a flurry of major network hits.
McClurg's voice is one of the things that
made her distinctive, too, and she's lent
it to animation many times, from "The Rugrats
Movie" to "Wreck-It Ralph." Sadly, in 2019,
McClurg's health began to decline, and her family
appointed a conservator to manage her affairs,
as she was no longer able to live unassisted.
In 2022, she was tragically the victim of
elder abuse and alleged sexual assault,
and her family successfully got an order
of protection against a longtime friend who
was alleged to have attempted to defraud her.
There are a few examples in "Ferris Bueller's
Day Off" of actors who come in for just one
scene but leave a lasting impression as
they get roped into Ferris' shenanigans
and schemes. Jonathan Schmock is arguably the
most memorable of these actors as the maitre
d' at a restaurant who refuses to believe
Ferris is the "Sausage King of Chicago."
"Are you suggesting I'm not who I say I am?"
"I'm suggesting that you leave
before I have to get snooty."
"Snooty?"
"Snotty."
"Snotty?"
Schmock had already been working for a few years
by the time he was hired for "Ferris Bueller,"
most notably on the TV series "Double Trouble,"
and has continued to make regular appearances in
film and TV. His more recent work includes guest
spots on "The Goldbergs," "Flaked," "Transparent,"
"2 Broke Girls," and more, but he's not just a
busy actor — Schmock is also an accomplished and
prolific screenwriter, particularly in the
realm of TV comedies. His credits include
co-developing "Sabrina the Teenage Witch,"
co-creating "Brotherly Love," and scripting
for shows like "Blossom," "Dharma & Greg," "Real
Time with Bill Maher," and "Young and Hungry."
Charlie Sheen has made a career as Hollywood's bad
boy. That image is perfectly apropos, considering
his part in "Ferris Bueller's Day Off" as a punk
teenager who romances Jennifer Grey's character.
"I meant are you in here for drugs?"
"Why are you here?"
"Drugs."
He took the role when he was on the cusp of
superstardom. The son of famed actor Martin Sheen,
Charlie had already appeared alongside Grey in
"Red Dawn," and after "Bueller" the actor had
a spectacular run that includes classics like
"Wall Street," "Platoon," and "Major League."
Sheen parlayed those '80s hits into modest
'90s success: After a pair of "Hot Shots"
parody movies, he tried his hand at becoming
an action star with "The Chase," "Terminal
Velocity," and the sci-fi thriller "The
Arrival." That never really panned out,
but in 2000 he took over for Michael J.
Fox as the lead in "Spin City." In 2003,
Sheen was cast as Charlie Harper in the hit
sitcom "Two and a Half Men." He remained
on the show until 2011, when clashes
with Chuck Lorre led to his departure.
A series of very public issues including drug
abuse and messy divorces plagued Sheen in
the 2010s, but in 2019, he revealed that
he'd been sober for more than a year and
was in therapy. In 2023, he and Lorre
buried the hatchet, and the actor was
handed a recurring role in the producer's
upcoming Max comedy "How to Be a Bookie."
"Bueller? Bueller? Bueller?"
Actor Ben Stein appears in only two scenes,
but he so perfectly embodies the archetype of
the tedious, droning high school teacher that
he carved out a niche as Hollywood's go-to guy
for playing monotone bores. Most memorably,
he portrayed teacher Mr. Cantwell in "The
Wonder Years," an airport customer service rep in
"Planes, Trains & Automobiles," and Rabbi Goldberg
on "Family Guy," not counting numerous cameos
as himself in a long-running eyedrops campaign.
Off-screen, Stein was a speechwriter for
Presidents Richard Nixon and Gerald Ford
and has written extensively on economics and
legal issues for the Wall Street Journal,
Fortune, and The New York Times. He starred
in two shows for Comedy Central: the talker
"Turn Ben Stein On" and the game show "Win Ben
Stein's Money," where contestants who demonstrated
more knowledge than the well-educated,
well-read Stein won a portion of his salary.
In recent years, Stein has mostly stayed
away from Hollywood and focused more on
being a spokesperson for the Republican Party. He
frequently appears on outlets like Fox News and
Newsmax. In 2023 he came under fire for racist
comments made about Aunt Jemima pancake syrup.
Kristy Swanson's role as Ferris' classmate
Simone Adamley wasn't quite a standout,
but audiences still know her, because less than
a decade on, Swanson originated the role of Buffy
in the "Buffy the Vampire Slayer" franchise. She
also played the titular role in "Mannequin Two:
On the Move," taking over for Kim
Cattrall from the 1987 cult classic.
Swanson's career in the 1990s was hit-or-miss,
but she did have an important role in the
well-received but ultimately doomed series
"Early Edition." She also appeared in a
variety of popular films, including the critically
acclaimed John Singleton drama "Higher Learning"
and the Joe Pesci crime comedy "8 Heads in a
Duffel Bag." Into the 2000s it was mostly TV
where Swanson made a name for herself, with a
recurring role in "Psych" and episodes of "CSI:
Miami" and "Just Shoot Me!" Though she's
mostly acted in cable channel TV movies
in the last decade, she did appear in a
trio of episodes of "SEAL Team" in 2019.
Actor Richard Edson plays the garage
attendant who sneaks off with Cameron's
car and goes for a joyride. It
was just his fourth acting role,
and he barely got any lines, but he appeared
in a host of major movies in the ensuing years.
Beginning with "Howard the Duck" and
"Platoon" the same year, Edson went on
to show up as Pvt. Abersold in "Good Morning,
Vietnam" and as Vito in "Do the Right Thing."
Edson's unique look allowed him to stand out,
too, and that has perhaps been the reason that
he's never been without work, even if he never did
become a big star. The '90s saw him showing up all
over film and TV, whether it was "The Adventures
of Pete & Pete" or the much-maligned "Super Mario
Bros." movie, in which he played Spike Koopa. We
could go on forever with all of the projects that
Edson has worked on, but no doubt you've seen him
around, as he's kept himself busy year after year,
with one of his more recent projects
being the indie film "Seeing Red" in 2022.
Not only was "Ferris Bueller" one of
Louie Anderson's first acting experiences,
his comedy career was also just getting started.
His role in the film had him playing a flower
deliveryman and gave him no lines at all. The
movie came to theaters just two years before
his first starring role, in 1988's "The Wrong
Guys," which was based on a story by John Hughes.
By the early '90s, Anderson was a huge comedy
star, and in 1994 he got his own animated
kid's show, "Life with Louie," which ran for
three seasons, then "The Louie Show." Though
Anderson continued with standup and could be
seen regularly on television, he became best
known for game shows. In the early 2000s, he was
hired as the host of the "Family Feud" revival
and made many appearances on "The New Hollywood
Squares" and "Hollywood Squares." He'd return
to the circuit in 2017, frequently appearing
as a guest star on "Funny You Should Ask."
In some of his final acting roles, Anderson
appeared on "Young Sheldon" in 2020 and had
roles in "Search Party" that same year
and "No Activity" a year later. Sadly,
Anderson died in 2022 from complications
caused by cancer, at the age of 68.
Actor Max Perlich played Ferris' snot-nosed
classmate who was "here" when Ben Stein called
out his name during roll call. Perlich may have
had little to say in the film, but his career is
an interesting one, starting with the fact that
he dropped out of high school to pursue acting,
with his first movie role being in the John
Hughes film. Despite having very little to say,
Perlich was able to turn his part
into more movie and TV appearances,
with his next projects including "Can't Buy
Me Love" and an episode of "21 Jump Street."
Though he's rarely had what would be
considered meaty roles, Perlich managed
to carve a niche for himself in the industry,
and some of his better-known films include
Mel Gibson's "Maverick" in 1994 and "Feeling
Minnesota" in 1996. Like many character actors,
he has shown up on tons of TV shows over the
years, from "Nash Bridges" and "Gilmore Girls"
to "The Shield" and "Crossing Jordan." He appears
as Hank in "Twin Peaks: The Return" as well.
But his biggest TV part was on the FX series
"Justified," where he played the sniveling mob
boss' son Sammy Tonin in four episodes of
the critically acclaimed crime drama. And
his constant work in the industry hasn't
been entirely thankless — Perlich won an
Independent Spirit Award for his supporting
performance in "Drugstore Cowboy" in 1990.
Jeffrey Jones' screen acting
career took off in the mid '70s,
thanks to being cast in projects like the
miniseries "The Adams Chronicles," and
by the 1980s he was an in-demand character
actor. After landing roles in "Easy Money,"
"Amadeus," and other projects, he was cast
as Ed Rooney in "Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
Jones continued to pick up major roles after his
"Bueller" success, starring in the short-lived,
Wes Craven-produced, off-the-wall forgotten
sitcom "The People Next Door." Surrounding
the failure of that show, he found safe harbor
in Tim Burton films like "Beetlejuice," "Ed
Wood," and "Sleepy Hollow." Other major
roles included being a conduit for the
Dark Overlord in "Howard the Duck," "The Hunt
for Red October," "The Crucible," "The Devil's
Advocate," and a role as newspaper publisher A.W.
Merrick in the acclaimed HBO series "Deadwood."
In 2003, Jones pleaded no contest to a charge of
employing a teenage boy to pose for nude photos,
and in 2010 he was sentenced to community
service for failing to update his sex
offender status. These legal issues led
to fewer screen appearances in the 2010s,
but in 2019 he did reprise his role
of Merrick in "Deadwood: The Movie."